welcome to this video playing down Mia
1813 18 13 years okay Kings onion maybe
I think since this I think this guy he
played a quite a bit of bullet games
against John Bartholomew somehow I
remember this this nameless handle let's
check there damia student okay one
minute he has got 30,000 one minute
games oh my god sake so this is the guy
I remember that he was very quick there
but ok this is five minutes chefs not
bullet Queen a5 is a funny sideline ok
so he does not mind this structural
deficit down I can check again can hear
and then knight c6 that looks quite nice
I mean I have my fair share of
experience with the NIMS oh and this
looks like a very nice names or with the
bishop on g7 you don't have given up
your bishop in the first place and it is
on g7 that's great so it probably has to
I guess I guess to Castle
knight c6 that can even take on c3 so
that's not going to work at all yeah so
castles let's cancel 95 maybe but I
don't want to spend ages on early moose
now in general I have tried to be a bit
quicker in recent games and I thinking
it helped in most in most cases with the
results I mean at least it helped okay
maybe I should have gone 95 really yeah
that was probably a good opportunity
okay i'm giving up a pawn them to get
get my development going oh I'm not even
i'm not giving up a pawn actually have
Quincy five check I didn't see that so
night takes be takes Bishop takes Queen
c5 check picks up the piece I was just
thinking that even if he just takes
twice I should have enough compensation
structural from structural point of view
but he cannot even take the pawn the
bishop on g2 those systems also in the
names oh very often are not easy to
handle because they always put this
pressure on c6 b7 makes the development
difficult what black did here 94-96 III
was trading time for structure and I'm
down on time wrong word and I'm behind
the development it's what I wouldn't
wanted to say and they have problems
with the bishop I'm surprised about that
that he takes that okay
that's really happening quite often hear
you think for a long time and you
overlook the simplest thing yeah the
difficult things design you have figured
out yeah rook p8 whatever and then
there's a simple simple tactic I'm
tactic yeah this is talk and he's doing
that maybe he's recording as well Jack
yeah Bishop t2 is synonymous actually
he's playing those moves out 95 was
possible and this is sorry it was maybe
maybe interesting okay he does does this
I cannot really influence that here yeah
I think 96 is just not not particularly
great if you cannot take on c6 it
doesn't make any sense to take so um
yeah probably would be one or something
instead of the CAPTCHA on c6 which is
probably I would assume about about
equal maybe I really should have played
95 probably where she going back here
very often there is compensation if you
lose this time I know that there are
those ideas from the NIMS oh I'm not
sure maybe I should have taken that it's
not not so clear what what is
compensation is exactly is active but
still computer gives equal here now I
think these six is a good idea it's hard
to untangle otherwise I expected
something like a groupie one but
thinking of it now maybe I can just take
a two were probably what this move maybe
this is probably good I go here I like
my position you have I have a very sound
porn structure with no weakness and I
have easy plans rook c8 and so on he has
to show what he what he what he has as a
compensation for the structural problems
probably look be one is a good move for
people
looking at this yeah that's that's okay
I think I don't think white has huge
trouble here the computer gives a slight
edge to black but it's this is
definitely a yeah a playable player
position for what the activity is very
very substantial okay well thanks for
watching